we begin with another grim chapter in
Spain's coronavirus crisis over 10,000
people have now died from complications
linked to Kovac 19 that's after a daily
record 950 people passed away in the
last 24 hours
Spain is now second only to Italy in the
number of virus fatalities the pandemic
is also hitting the country's economy
hard nearly a million people have lost
their jobs since mid-march meanwhile the
country's health care workers are
overwhelmed and lacking critical
protective gear stretched to breaking
points the wards are full at this
hospital in Alicante so coronavirus
patients lie in the corridors just north
of Barcelona medics have turned the
hospital library into an intensive care
unit Spain is one of the worst hit
countries the number of coronavirus
deaths has now jumped to more than
10,000 after a record 950 deaths in the
space of a day the health workers on the
frontline say they are being put in an
unthinkable position we are lacking the
staff at the moment and the few staff
that we have available are in a
dangerous situation themselves and at
risk of becoming transmitters I got
infected because of the lack of
protective measures as we don't have
enough resources there are fewer and
fewer suitable protective masks somebody
is doing things really badly and we need
them to rectify this because if they
don't do so tomorrow we will double the
number of infected health workers if we
continue like this there would be enough
professionals to take care of our
patients but there are glimmers of hope
the rate of new infections in Spain
appears to be slowing and people are
recovering here at a hospital in the
northeast of the country doctors
discharged a 93 year old man who has
made a full recovery after five days in
isolation
Spain has been in a nationwide lockdown
since the middle of March and the
standstill is hitting the economy hard
900,000 people have lost their jobs and
Spain's recorded its highest ever
monthly rise in unemployment the
government says it will have to work on
relaunching the economy once the
epidemic is under control
health officials say data shows the
curve is stabilizing
but despite the slowdown in the rate of
infections the fight to contain the
virus is far from over
well that's bringing TW correspondent
Yann Philip Schultz in Spain and despite
the nationwide lockdown the number of
deaths has reached a new high is there
anything else that can be done here are
there any other further measures under
discussion to help save lives
well the measures here in Spain were
just tightened some days ago and
together with Italy they're by far the
strictest in Europe now only employees
of the so-called essential sectors can
go to work and even small walks are
prohibited now so spaniards ask
themselves how much stricter can the
measures be and also the government
announced today that it would start
using mobile phone data to track
people's movements the official stress
that it's hundred percent anonymous and
that it will be only used to analyze the
measures and not for law enforcement
purposes but of course some some
Spaniards are sceptic about it just in
terms of the the profile demographic of
the the sick and the dead which
population groups are being worst hit by
the crisis in Spain well it's it's the
elderly people who have been hit the
hardest by far which is especially
tragic of course because they are also
the most vulnerable group the news from
nursing homes all over the country is
very disturbing the mayor of Barcelona
said today that up to 70 percent of the
nursing homes in the city might be
affected by by the corona virus but of
course we also have to be
with those official statistics because
the the testing capacities are very
limited and there might also be a lot of
younger people infected but with mild
symptoms and not gestured turning to the
economics nine hundred thousand people
have already lost their jobs what help
can they expect well that's that's a
good question it's true that the month
of March has been the worst in the
history of the Spanish economy and the
the government has been rolling out new
measures almost on a daily basis for the
people that are worse affected by the
crisis there are some immediate measures
in place now among them are the Stop of
evictions direct financial aid and also
easy accessible loans but almost all
experts agree that this is not enough
and the Spanish people have some very
very hard economic days and weeks and
months ahead and Philip Schultz in Spain
thank you well Russian President
Vladimir Putin has extended the
country's coronavirus locked down until
April 30 all citizens with the exception
of essential workers are to stay at home
with all salaries to be paid throughout
this period in a televised address Putin
stressed the seriousness of the threat
facing the country and that the peak of
the virus still lay ahead
know what you need you know of yellen's
the non-working week declared all over
the country as well as self-isolation
regime for residents of many regions
allowed us to win some time for
preventive actions to mobilize all the
authorities to increase healthcare
resources to fight the epidemic with
maximum efficiency using both our own
experience and the best practice of
other countries
lutely a practically druggie we're
joined now by DW correspondent Emily
show and in Moscow
Emily President Putin calls they say
non-working period or even a nationwide
corona
holiday what is behind this language
well the language of courses is rather
euphemistic last week
Putin already announced a week-long
holiday and the Kremlin followed that
announcement with an encouraging
statement saying that people should
actually be encouraged to keep working
now of course this positive wording that
Putin is using essentially allows him to
be the good guy he talked about the fact
that different regions in Russia have
been affected to different extents and
he called on regional governors and
mayors of cities to kind of implement
their own measures according to the
seriousness of the situation in
different regions and that of course
means that the regional authorities will
have to essentially be the bad bad guys
when they Institute strict measures now
we've already seen Moscow put people in
self-isolation last week in many regions
following Moscow in within Russia has
been the hardest hit there have been
around 3,500 cases across the country in
2,500 of them around that number are in
Moscow and this week the city
authorities have been discussing how
they're going to be implementing those
self-isolation measures next week using
smart technologies like facial
recognition and using the geolocation
data from people's mobile phones and
Moscow has been kind of a testing ground
for measures so we're likely to see
strict measures in other regions as well
and how are the people in Russia
reacting to these measures that you
talked about well last week when Putin
announced this kind of week-long
coronavirus holiday as you called it
people kind of took him by his word some
people booked flights to the Black Sea
city of Sochi there were images on
social media of people in Moscow
barbecuing and then the authorities took
rather strict measures for example by
closing hotels in Sochi by imposing the
self-isolation in the capital I think
people now have understood the
seriousness of this and the fact that
these are essentially just euphemisms
Moscow certainly is rather empty there's
hardly any traffic there are billboards
around the city calling on people to
stay home presenters on state TV are
presenting from their living rooms some
of them are wearing masks
to encourage people to kind of stay home
as well and I think people are starting
to understand that here as well and they
are likely to understand it even better
better if strict measures come into
force as well across the country
Emily Sherwin in Moscow thank you in
South America Brazil has the most cases
of the coronavirus and the highest death
toll almost 7,000 people have been
infected that includes the first
coronavirus case among its indigenous
population the country's president gibe
Olsen ro has been under fire for his
handling of the pandemic last month he
referred to Co vid 19 as quote a measly
cold he's also the only major world
leader continuing to criticize lockdown
measures designed to slow the spread of
the virus it was a deliberate
provocation by President Jaya bolson ro
visiting a supermarket surrounded by
shoppers right in the middle of the
coronavirus crisis bowl scenario himself
may be infected with the virus this is
why he chose to mingle all the same
should I have the corona virus I as a
former athlete don't need to worry I
wouldn't notice anything at the most a
touch of the flu or a cold our families
must be able to feed themselves that's
why we should now all be returning to
normal
people in Rio de Janeiro's biggest
shanty town took their president at his
word after days of isolation residents
went back to work shrugging off the
dangers of the virus the local mayor
fears he may soon be dealing with an
epidemic it'll be a disaster we've
already been fighting in tuberculosis
outbreak residents don't realize that
they would be safer staying at home
crisis is escalating
unlike bolson RO brazil's provincial
governors acted from the start shutting
Beach's schools and supermarkets
scientists are warning that the crisis
is just beginning we estimate that the
epidemic curve in Brazil will peak in
two to three weeks the infection rate is
constantly increasing across Brazil
coronavirus victims are being buried and
young people are among the dead these
scenes have sparked protests residents
have been banging pans in anger at
Belsen RO
he eventually backtracked we have a
mission to save lives without
threatening jobs we have to focus on
both the virus and the economy in an
apparent u-turn bolson ro now wants to
fight the virus but too late to prevent
him losing many supporters who now see
him as irresponsible for more on this
were joined now from Rio de Janeiro by
the correspondent who filed that report
Matias Abbott but is do we know where
paulsen ro has been getting his
information from and why he brushed off
warnings for so long as we see there are
two major wings inside his own
government and in the last week's the
predominant wing were the science
deniers religious groups who advised him
to talk in the way we saw on the report
but on Tuesday this changed the wing of
the militaries and the science friendly
groups inside his government yet told
him to lower his voice and to not
anymore
talk against isolation measures so now
both now is much more moderate than
before regional leaders have taken the
initiative to warn people on their own
in some cases is the country's health
care system also ready for an onslaught
of infections
the public healthcare system of Brazil
is much better than in other countries
here in South America the governors of
the different states in Sao Paulo and
Rio Janeiro they are constructing
special hospitals and temporarily
hospitals with more beds for Corona
cases for example in the famous Maracana
stadium and also in the San boardroom
the the carnival temple of Rio de
Janeiro so there are measures taken but
we have to see and wait for the numbers
of death and an infection see in Brazil
and this would be really yeah not sure
we are not sure so far if it will be
enough and if two people will have
access and quickly what about Brazil's
indigenous people Mateus and the threat
to them yeah they are vulnerable and
they went to the Amazon forest many
groups tribes went back to the Amazon
because they have no antibodies and as
they know from the memories that further
former generations suffered from
diseases brought by white people so they
went back some groups and they want to
hide deep inside the forest
correspondent Mateus EBIT reporting from
Rio thank you